public trust in a government has gone
from 75 to 77 under Johnson then all the
way down to
it was down with Nixon down with four
down with Carter uh and then up with
Reagan downward Bush up with Clinton
downward Bush down with Obama a little
bit of up with Trump and then flat with
Biden the American people don't trust me
well I can't read it what is it that's
just a public trust in the government
what's the percentage today the
percentage today is less than 20 percent
20 it's even worse it's worse today than
it was it's ever been you know I mean go
under Obama Obama's was the lowest ever
where people trusted America it hit 19
under Obama heels 15 percent under Obama
where people didn't trust the the
government uh and by the way I would be
curious to know what that event is that
caused it to drop to 19 that's a 17 15
or 17 15 so yeah people don't trust them
so you know again to me not trusting the
government what is the government I
think people don't trust the swamp is so
they don't trust the people within the
government they don't trust us it's not
what it was before uh how do we how do
we get there how do you think we got
here to have this little of a trust in
the government well in in my opinion
when when you have a series of events
which um you know are I believe are kind
of like the equivalent of earthquakes in
the 1960s all right when you have you
know at four assassinations
all right that took place in a period of
five years under the most suspicious
circumstances and the and the government
and the Department of Justice don't do
anything
about them all right and this is what I
believe it eventually led to the
combination of the extension of the
Vietnam War
and to Watergate all right and in my
opinion since then it's it's essentially
been a kind of downward curve sense you
know
um the Watergate scandal took place over
two solid years all right and so you
know to restore the trust of the people
in the government
I really believe it's almost a lost
cause now I guess I like fighting for
lost causes okay please keep doing that
keep doing that you know what would be
an interesting thing for for you guys to
investigate next
uh I had a guy on uh General Spalding I
don't know if you're familiar with
General Spalding or not uh and
um uh General Spaulding says one day
he's given he's being asked he's working
for uh the U.S government he's being
asked he was a former general of the Air
Force lived in China for a long time he
was there to learn about the systems of
China comes over here
and he's telling her what China's vision
is long term
and on one side McConnell is sitting
down the other side Biden's sitting
there both of them were not happy about
his message about China because
McConnell's wife
there's lineage goes back to China and
the the power that his wife has and then
obviously Biden's linked to China as
well neither one is happy and then he
says immediately I got fired right after
they hired me to teach them about China
and then all of a sudden I'm being fired
I think James if whatever you choose to
investigate next and study
I would be very curious if you would
have any interest in studying the swamp
and seeing what really goes on within
the political world you know how people
say they they they don't want this to be
released they don't want people to know
they well the title of the book should
be who is they okay let's go figure out
who this they Community is the they
party right because once we figure out
that they people who are protecting all
these things from people knowing about
it I think then then we can lead to
accountability but I think if you wrote
that book uh you would need 24 7
protection to to make sure you're safe
and I don't know if you want to live
that kind of a life
probably not so what all the craziness
taking place I believe future looks
bright if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of valuetainment it says
future looks bright here future looks
bright here we got them in white we got
them in Black we got them in red our
black on black sold out these are about
to sell out if you haven't ordered one
yet we had a person in Michigan but one
then he bought three then when those
three people wore it in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks bright toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]